after four days of intensifying protests
and widespread opposition from lawmakers
president ivan duque didn't have many
options left but to withdraw his
controversial tax reform
le solicito al congreso i'm asking
congress to withdraw the law proposed by
the finance ministry
and urgently process a new law that is
the fruit of consensus
in order to avoid financial uncertainty
the reform is not a whim
the reform is a necessity to withdraw it
or not was not the discussion
the real discussion is to be able to
guarantee the continuity
of social programs
celebratory casero lassos beating on
pots and pans could be heard in the
capital bogota just minutes after the
announcement on friday duke had already
promised to make
changes to the law removing the most
controversial points
like new taxes on food but in the face
of a growing death toll
looting an accusation of abuses by the
police he pulled it all together
protesters hailed the announcement as a
victory but they still have a long list
of grievances
and say that the protest will continue
there's also labor reform pension and
health reform
the issue of corruption the increasing
violence against community leaders
the protest will continue and we will
not grow tired
some analysts in the country consider a
tax reform necessary to stabilize
colombia's finances and maintain its
international debt
credit but blame the government for
pushing forward the bill
nobody liked the government still could
have prevented
all the pain and all the suffering that
went into the first four days of
protests if it had at least listened
to people if he had listened and
consulted
with the political parties if he had
listened and consulted
with public opinion but they decided
despite everything to go ahead and
introduce the reform
in spite of their knowledge that it was
deeply unpopular some parts of it
the withdrawal shows just how isolated
president duque is in a country
increasingly on edge while he's hoping
to gather support for a revised
tax reform with less than a year to go
before new elections
the political reality on the streets and
in congress
might make it unlikely alessandra
al jazeera bogota